[Music]
[Music]
it's a very merry
boozy throwback r b christmas at the
kardashian house
it's been a lot of fun on sunday kim
kardashian hit up her insta story to
share a few videos from her family
holiday dinner
and the reality star admitted she was so
deep in the sauce
she didn't even remember taking them
[Music]
yeah that's kim channeling her inner
brandy and monica circa 1998
with her mom kris jenner's long time
beau corey
gamble and that's kim posing with santa
while her big sis
kourtney kardashian hides behind the
chair with a stick pony
yeah court appeared to be having a jolly
old time too
and was living her best cowgirl life
kim prefaced those tipsy clips with this
post
writing funny i found these videos in my
phone from last night and don't remember
complete with three martini emojis
but back to court and that stick pony
i love it apparently the 41 year old was
having so much fun with her new toy
kylie jenner dedicated an
entire tic toc post to quote courtney
and her little christmas pony a love
story
jolly christmas it's the best time
of the year now i don't know
if there'll be snow but have a cup of
cheer
now there's a montage we never knew we
always needed
if you look close right there that's a
rare appearance from
rob kardashian and while the adults were
having a great time
so were the kids scott disick posted
this clip of north
saint penelope and a few other family
friends
doing tick tock's hakka challenge
inspired by a ceremonial dance in the
maori culture
of course all this comes after the
kardashian jenner crew announced that
they wouldn't be hosting their annual
christmas eve bash this year due to the
rising coronavirus cases in california
khloe kardashian shared the news after
one fan asked about the status of the
soiree on twitter
explaining in part quote it's the first
time we will not be having a christmas
eve party since 1978 i believe
health and safety first though taking
this pandemic seriously
is a must coco tested positive for covet
19
back in the spring and experience some
pretty bad
symptoms all documented on keeping up
with the kardashians of course
the coughing my chest would burn when i
would cough
and i mean i still my throat is still
not fully recovered clearly let me tell
you
that is real but
we're all gonna get through this praying
if we follow orders and listen we're all
gonna
be okay and while the famous fam has
seemingly scaled back during the 2020
pandemic
they've also caught some heat for
hosting large gatherings
like kendall's halloween themed birthday
bash and kim's 40th birthday getaway
she flew a group of family and friends
to a private island to celebrate
entering a new decade of life
it was such a beautiful experience and i
want kim to focus on just how beautiful
it was and what she did for everybody i
mean
i don't want that to overshadow chloe
responded to the backlash during an
appearance on the ellen degeneres show
this year is a frustrating year i get it
i think there's
so many frustrations going on for
everybody
but also it's her 40th and this is
something that she really wanted to do
for us it was such a nice thing